[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans si on
parlait sport le cinquième épisode de
cette saison sur tv à 60,18 ce mercredi
à 18 novembre pour cette un jour de cet
enregistrement nous sommes toujours en
confinement mais nous allons essayer de
vous redonner le sourire en cette fin
d'année 2020 qui il ne faut pas se
mentir n'a pas été une année
exceptionnelle pour le monde du sport
loin de là pour nous redonner le sourire
j'ai fait appel à la dream team à
présentation quand on parle de dream
team on pense forcément à notre russell
crowe yvelinois il est avec nous en
plateau c'est un grand sportif il adore
le golf et le rugby notre gladiateurs
pierre chevallier est avec nous pendant
une heure du rugby-club de versailles
salut michael salut à tous
quand avez vous écouté en pleine forme
en forme de movember est malgré tout
malgré tout près après à dispenser de la
forme et du bonheur et du sourire et du
sourire en cette période à un petit peu
particulière on verra ça dans cette
émission on passe de l'autre côté
musique vous reconnaissez sa musique il
est là c'est sa cinquième titularisation
dans cette émission les journalistes
chez tv 78 et un spécialiste de football
c'est également une encyclopédie vivante
sur le sport yvelinois sa popularité ne
cesse de monter l'italienne lover
grégory canal est avec nous en fait un
peu trop mutuelle comment ça va ça va et
vous battre est bien toujours heureux
d'être avec la team on s'entretient en
ce moment vu que le sport amateur est à
l'arrêt mais on est content de parler de
sport tout le temps est-ce que vous avez
un message à faire passer à vos fans aux
nombreux fans un message à faire passer
à mes fans je sais pas aimez vous les
uns les autres
voilà bien préparé mais le message de
cette année 2020 c'est ça alors le sont
donc trois en plateau les eaux sont avec
nous via écran interposé à cause du
contexte sanitaire je le disais
précédemment
on le surnomme dans cette émission le
capitaine musique
il est champion du monde sur piste
master's apparemment il a beaucoup à
travailler sur cette émission c'est
assez rare pour le souligner a gagné
jarrier du club de vélizy
78 est avec nous bonsoir je me rate
allez-vous le super super ça va bien ça
va bien on fait avec
avec les conditions du moment et puis
puis ben vi on essaie de vivre ça au
mieux et ça vous oblige apparemment à
bosser vous avez bossé l'émission je
suis sur un très bon rythme en ce moment
et un effet comme comme l'actualité me
brûler particulièrement et bien en effet
j'ai un peu plus travaillée
qu'habituellement
voilà vous ne pouvez pas mettre les
voiles mais vous parlez de vous allez
parler de voile dans cette émission lui
aussi est connecté via écran interposé
musique c'est un fan de sport et plus
particulièrement de football et de
saint-etienne il vit pour le spoil et
respire sport quand ils rêvent
il rêve également de sport ça nous fait
plaisir de le voir dans cette émission
et stéphane de visée est avec nous
pendant une heure comment ça va ça va et
vous comment allez-vous stéphane je
trouve que ton fait passer avec moi
c'est dommage bon c'est vrai c'est le
niveau la prochaine fois on verra ça
j'aimerais juste ni regret une pensée
pour mes amis handisport qui sont
coincés chez eux qu'ils peuvent pas
faire de sport
j'aimerais leur dire qu'ils se
renseignent quand même à leur mairie
parce qu'il existe des dérogations pour
que les sportifs handicapés puis 20 puis
ce pardon continuer leurs activités
sportives là ça va se faire sur des
rails on va reprendre le handibasket
donc il ya des aléas voir à la mairie
renseignez vous ça peut le faire le
message est passé stéphane merci
beaucoup
enfin une dernière personne sera avec
nous aujourd'hui musique c'est une
grande première pour lui dans ce talk et
je sais qu'il sera à la hauteur
à 34 ans il joue actuellement à trappes
en tant que basketteur mais il a joué en
professionnel à monaco à voir ou à
nicosie il a voyagé a partout en europe
mais il est là aujourd'hui dans cette
émission
mike est avec nous pendant une heure
bonjour michel maïque mans au congo
quand allez-vous ça va très bien et où
comment vous sentez-vous pour cette
première sa voix tranquille ça a l'air
d'avoir une bonne ambiance est en tout
cas je suis je suis ravi d'être parmi
vous n'allez pas être déçus en tout cas
pour l'ambiance alors avant de passer au
programme de cette émission nous allons
parler de la coupe de france de football
c'est officiel le huitième et les 32e de
finale de coupe de france qui devait se
dérouler le 13 décembre et les 2 et 3
janvier sont décalée à une date
ultérieure la raison les championnats
amateurs ne peuvent plus se disputer et
les 6e tour de coupe de france n'a pas
pu se jouer pour rappel l'équipe de
conflent et qualifié pour le 6e tour et
devait jouer le 1er novembre contre
vitry avant que le match ne soit
reportée est ce que cette décision est
logique
oui ou non oui c'est logique
oui alors grégory logique ce qu'on lève
cette coupe de france c'est une
compétition en dehors du championnat qui
permet à des équipes de faire des
parcours plus ou moins lointain alors on
a parlé à des club yvelinois je l'aurais
porter un petit peu la poisse info le
rappeler sur ce plateau
mais il reste un représentant les
menaces représentées je peux aller
jusqu'à la finale je ne dirai rien sur
sur sur le mont pronostics mais en tout
cas oui on est bien content conflent qui
aura l'occasion de faire parler aussi de
cette ville d'une autre manière il ya
une actualité récente qui n'est pas
forcément très belle donc non décision
logique et on l'espère on aura une date
assez vite ce qu'on espère qu'on va
avoir cette date assez vite pierre
chevalier logique respectée tout à fait
puisque c'est la coupe de france et le
rugby lui
pardon le football pro contre ou avec le
football amateur donc évidemment c'est
un mélange d un mélange déjà mélange des
genres les pros peuvent continuer à
s'entraîner ça aura été tout à fait
inéquitable que le que le football
amateur ne pouvant s'entraîner puis deux
doivent continuer la coupe de france et
puis je retiens aussi que c'est un on va
dire en gagne deux mois pour les
pronostics de grégory avait toujours un
club yvelinois en piste de moyens - vous
êtes comme moi mais on verra que doit à
ce train là
ce travail est encore en piste en mois
de mai pour confiance en son honneur il
ya du jarrier ben c'est ce que vous
allez dire ça à dire c'est vrai qu'il va
moi je pense que la plus grosse
problématique va être de pouvoir jouer
la finale pendant l'euro voilà là on va
commencer à rencontrer des petits soucis
mais voilà on n'a pas le choix il faut
il faut s'adapter il faut faire avec
et puis advienne poids simplement cette
coupe de france peut-être même si elle a
commencé ce qu'il faut pas l'annuler
s'était passé ce qui pourrais je ne fais
pas ça je ne peux pas vous dire je sais
juste que les conditions de préparation
sont pas les mêmes pour le niveau
amateur
ils sont quasiment à l'arrêt donc ce
weel arrêtez enfin non moi je serais
plutôt pour que ça continue
après il ya que pour l'instant
saint-etienne quel niveau amateur 1 j'ai
la haine
il faudra trouver des dates à un mic oui
c'est sûr c'est sûrement tout cas ce qui
est ce qui est important c'est d'essayer
de pdc de faire participer tout le monde
que ce soit aujourd'hui le sport amateur
comme les sports co décidé trouver un
équilibre pour que tout - soit à peu
près se retrouve un peu par rapport à
cette situation d'aujourd'hui c'est vrai
que le plus important c'est c'est pas
forcément les statuts dans le sport
comme j'ai dit c'est ce côté où tout le
monde se réunit pour pouvoir jouer
partager des bons moments ensemble et
donc c'est ça qui est le plus important
aujourd'hui parce que c'est vrai qu'à 10
tentation sociale ça facilite pas tout
ça donc voilà il faut qu'on essaie de
trouver un terrain d'entente pour tout
le monde en tout cas on souhaite bon
courage à conflans conçu avec attention
à grégory
pour être une belle fête pour la reprise
la reprise du foot amateur le foot l
amateur qui à l'arrêt comme l'ensemble
des sports amateurs ça pourrait être une
belle fête pour reprendre le foot magie
la coupe de france il ya c'est justement
qu'on garde cet ce côté complètement
imprévisible des coûts des du football
amateur contre les contre les pros et
qu'on puisse quand même leur laisser un
peu de temps pour se repréparer est
justement être compétitif face à des
clubs pros dans ce contexte très
particulier mais là nous l'annuler ça
serait peut-être dommage sauf si il
n'est pas possible vraiment il n'est
plus possible de maintenir pour les
instances légales et les dates les
agendas c'est le vrai que ça va être le
vrai problème dans tous les sports on
l'exemple par exemple de marseille qui a
déjà vu son match contre lens reporter
son match également contre aunis qui va
être reportée et puis ça fait déjà deux
dates qu'il faut retrouver par exemple
pour ça va même lui même jusqu'au équipe
nationale on voit on le week-end dernier
sur l'équipe de france de rugby dont le
match contre les fidji a été annulé donc
là c'est vraiment annulé par porter bon
là il ya aura pas d'embouteillages mais
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment le
problème des dettes d'agenda dont
parlait mike et dont parlait yann qui va
se poser dès le début du mois de janvier
yann nigeria oui parce que en fait j'ai
levé la main simplement il faut pas
oublier c'est que déjà dans le top 14
on a annulé les phases finales pour
pouvoir pour pouvoir faire au moins
jouer le championnat sur les matches
aller retour
donc cette année sur le top 14 il n'y
aura pas de aura pas de file et voilà il
y aura pas de on prendra pas les
diviseurs de cire chez me dit c'est pour
le rugby amateur aux amateurs ça c'est
le même intervalle oui
maintenant mes douze possibles donc en
effet sur une coupe de france puisque
les notes des animateurs et d'amateurs
ne peut pas se préparer
les amateurs ne peuvent pas s'entraîner
correctement si on lève le relève le
confinement aller 1er décembre si on
peut le permettre de rêver ou alors me
descendre pour pour pouvoir aller
tranquillement à noël en famille mais
personne ne va pouvoir s'entraîner avant
le mois de janvier
et comment comment ils vont pouvoir
alors rencontré des équipes parce qu'ils
ont deux divisions supplémentaires ou
alors des vraiment des équipes qui elles
auront pu continuer de s'entraîner parce
qu'ils ont un niveau professionnel il ya
quand même des moments où là il ya une
vraie difficulté sur cette compétition
c'est possible en effet qu elles parce
qu'elles passent à la trappe et que les
instances disent stop stop stop stop ou
de francs soit parce que ça rentrera pas
dans le calendrier et qu'il faudra
rattraper c'est un match même de liga
puisque comme vous dites marseille
marseille a déjà au moins de dommages de
retard alors merci d'avoir réagi autant
à sur cette thématique ce n'était pas
forcément prévu alors nous allons
maintenant passer au programme de
l'émission
aujourd'hui nous allons parler du vendée
globe 2020 à louis burton originaire de
rambouillet fait une belle course pour
le moment tous les détails dans ce talk
coup de projecteur également sur les jo
de 2024 et le match entre versailles et
la motte beuvron pour accueillir à
l'équitation
mais avant de développer ces thèmes on
va parler du confinement et des sportifs
de haut niveau
depuis le début du confinement une
centaine de sportifs de haut niveau du
département sont sur liste ministérielle
et peuvent continuer à s'entraîner
normalement cette dérogation leur permet
de se préparer physiquement et
techniquement pour les prochaines
échéances c'est le cas pour les
tennismans du comité de tennis de
feucherolles on écoute lundi sportif
classé dans les espoirs dans la
structure donc en fait il ya des de haut
niveau et sportive jeunes au niveau et
je figure dessus on his l'espoir du coup
j'ai fait droit nous entraîner donc je
m'entraîne ici la semaine avec des
partenaires qui sont pareils sur 10 au
niveau et le week end je peux pas aller
dans mon club parce que basses et fermé
c'est vrai que c'est quand même une
chance qu est-ce qui s'est entraîné
aujourd'hui alors que je sais qu'il ya
beaucoup de monde qui aimeraient être à
ma place ici à feucherolles ils sont une
dizaine à s'entraîner du matin au soir
un vrai plus par rapport au premier
confinement selon les encadrants pendant
le premier confinement du mois de mars
en fait les enfants ont continué à faire
du travail physique chez eux
mais malgré tout ils ont quand même
beaucoup perdu et on a mis du temps à
retrouver un niveau correct donc la
halle avantage c'est que les
entraînements se poursuivent donc il ya
moins de pertes c'est tennisman ne sont
pas les seuls à s'entraîner à dans les
yvelines ils sont des centaines de
sportifs à avoir obtenu cette fameuse
dérogation dans les catégories espoir
aux élites on retrouve notamment des
athlètes susceptibles de partir aux jo
de tokyo l'été prochain comme à
versailles et thomas à baruch médaillé
de bronze en aviron en 2016 à rio en
l'écoutent
si on n'avait pas pu aller dehors
s'entraîner sur l'eau on aurait quand
même pu faire ce qu'on a fait au
printemps dernier
continuer le travail physique sa part
exhorté le trail physiologique mais
voilà dans le sport il n'ya pas que de
la physiologie et aussi beaucoup de
technique beaucoup de de précision et de
sensations et quand on n'est pas sur
l'eau mais on ne va pas cette dérogation
s'appliquera jusqu'à la fin du
confinement au minimum jusqu'au premier
à décembre la question sur cette
thématique cette mesure est elle
suffisante pour garantir le sport de
haut niveau
partager pour grégory partage également
pour pourront pierre
oui pour vous y allez vous êtes comment
vous mike partage également partagé bien
sûr et non sur franco américain
qu'est-ce que vous qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
alors moi je moi je pense tout d'abord
il est important d'éviter tous les
problèmes de classes sociales
parce que pour moi un sportif reste un
sportif que ce soit un sportif de haut
niveau ou un sportif amateur
le plus important c'est d'essayer de
trouver un terrain d'entente pour tout
le monde alors au jour d'aujourd'hui
avec ses difficultés de pandémie on a
l'impression que il ya des classes qui
sont un peu plus privilégiés que deux
gosses et ce genre de choses pour écrire
énormément de problèmes dans la société
de nous vivons aujourd'hui et je pars
toujours du principe où on est tous des
êtres humains et et que notre existence
sur la terre et dépend pas de la classe
sociale
maintenant c'est qu'il ya un business
cas autour du sport qui est réel parce
que c'est vrai que c'est un business
mais maintenant il faut essayer de
trouver un terrain d'entente pour que
pour que voilà que ce soit le sport
copie s'est déroulé et puis aussi les
amateurs parce que je reviens aussi sur
les amateurs parce que c'est
c'est une structure qui est un peu
négligé par les par les grandes
instances et et ça c'est important c'est
important de le dire
donc voilà on vu dans une société qui
est diverse et il faut essayer de
satisfaire tout le monde chevallier il
ya deux choses qui me qu'il semble
importante a souligné la première c'est
l'anticipation par rapport au premier
confinement dire ce qu'on n'a pas pu
faire lors du premier confinement
notamment au niveau du sport amateur a
été fait là maintenant
lors de ce deuxième c'est de pouvoir
anticiper sur le maximum de moyens qu'il
y avait pour pouvoir maintenir au moins
une activité physique notamment au
niveau du haut niveau du sport amateur
le rugby que je connais le footballeur
on vient d'en parler et la deuxième
chose c'est il ya ya ya comme une comme
disait mike il ya quand même une
différence de traitement entre le sport
professionnel
donc là en l'occurrence les sportives et
sportifs de haut niveau et le sport
amateur plus peut-être plus loisirs où
il va manquer un élément essentiel est
qu'il manque aussi sur la partie
professionnelle je pense c'est la
compétition donc le vraiment le la
préparation mentale mais ils ne peuvent
pas dans ces conditions ils peuvent pas
se mesurer ils peuvent les sportifs
professionnels peuvent s'entraîner en
conditions réelles ça c'est une serait
ce que pour la deuxième une différence
par rapport au sport amateur mais parce
que même entre sportifs de haut niveau
exactement les amateurs eux ne peuvent
entretenir que le physique et palpable
le jeu avec ballon avec raquettes ou
roulent leurs armes leur sport ou leurs
agrès mais ce qui va manquer c'est
justement cet aspect mental c'est sp
compétition et se mesurer donc c'est
pour ça que j'étais un peu partagé les
plus tôt à tendre vers le nom en disant
on ne peut pas se jauger et la dea et
les échanges arrive selon les sports qui
arrive selon les sports sont quand même
relativement importante et un euro de
foot pour les professionnels de football
il ya plein de plein déchéance qui ont
été décalés et la pouvoir se préparer
vraiment dans les meilleures conditions
il manquera il manquera un peu de celles
des bourgeois n'ya justement alors
effectivement le même plan que pierre
chevalier ce qui m'a fait dire que
j'étais mitigé c'est effectivement le
côté compétition il ya effectivement
beaucoup d'athlètes qui peuvent
continuer le sport de haut niveau en
tout cas l'entraînement et ça c'est une
bonne chose
l'entraîneur de tennis qu'on a qu'on a
entendu le disait
le premier confinement a fait perdre
beaucoup d'automatismes à ces sportifs
et du coup on sait que ce fardeau venir
ça a pris deux voire trois mois pour
récupérer certainement les automatismes
c'est que dans le sport doit organiser
notamment n'y a pas il n'y a pas de
hasard les décors les techniques sont
réglées au millimètre si vous vous
arrêtez pendant deux à trois mois est
effectivement il faut rattraper le
retard maintenant le côté compétition je
rejoins tout à fait pierre sur cet
aspect ça permet aussi en plus de se
jauger vis-à-vis de l'adversaire
d'accumuler du rythme parce que le
rythme des matches sur plusieurs sports
n'est pas le même que l'on peut avoir
lors des entraînements donc c'est pour
ça que je suis mitigé effectivement
bonne chose pour les entraînements mais
le cockpit le côté compétition qui
manque à mon sens stéphane de bizet vous
êtes d'accord avec grégory avec pierre
chevalier lewis et c'est un plus c'est
bien je vois pour le rugby fauteuil
reprendre les entraînements en gymnase
et hop ça permet de re travailler en
équipe vous êtes l'un des rouages le
précise balawi parce qu'on a une
dérogation
on va pouvoir reprendre reprendre nos
marques sur des terrains bayer avec les
copains mais c'est sur ce qui va manquer
ce avec les matches et il ya les jeux
paralympiques qui vont arriver
est-ce que ça va pas vous nous comment
dire nous mettre un peu en retrait
contrairement à d'autres à droite à
d'autres équipes
oui justement on l'a vu il ya thomas
barrau qui doit peut-être partie audio
tokyo le l'été prochain s'ils ont lieu
je sais à préciser s'ils ont lieu il ya
également victor lévesque qui lui dans
l'équitation qui doit partir lui aussi
finalement si on leur arrête tout on les
tue et on peut on peut le dire carrément
yann jarrier on l'est on les cramer en
tout cas pour la compétition aujourd'hui
à 8
on est à combien d 1,8 neuf mois des jo
en effet sans aucun entraînement
aujourd'hui un athlète qui prépare une
échéance comme les jeux olympiques
s'il peut pas s'entraîner pendant un
mois et demi il est out pour yahoo pour
mission bien sûr une athlète de haut
niveau déjà une olympiade ça serait pas
sur quatre ans et le travail de la
dernière année alors cette année vise à
fin cette fois-ci bizarrement ils ont 5
ans donc c'est vrai que il a fallu
s'adapter depuis confinement depuis le
premier confinement et depuis le report
des jeux le décalage des jeux sur une
année il a fallu modifier les programmes
d'entraînement et donc et donc du coup
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui un arrêt qui
pourrait pas s'entraîner normalement
pour préparer cette échéance serait
neutre et parts égales par rapport à des
têtes qui eux peuvent pour s entraîner
s'est entraîné normalement et est en
effet on rattrape pas un mois et demi
d'entraînement en l'espace de six mois
c'est impossible
une préparation d'une échéance comme
celle là c'est assez un an un an où il
faut être
focus il ne pensait qu'à ça govou qui y
est vous qui étiez sportifs de très haut
niveau
qu'est ce que vous en pensez non je
rejoins je rejoins tout ce que tout le
monde a pu dire parce que bon c'est vrai
que sportif de haut niveau il a besoin
de de s'entraîner ça c'est sûr de
manière régulière et aussi de compétir
c'est-à-dire de participer aux
compétitions d'exercer s'accomplira
façon d'exercer sa discipline face à
face aux autres équipes et c'est quelque
chose qui est fondamental parce qu on se
rend bien compte que le rythme le ter
facilement et puis il ya aussi l'aspect
mental qui est très très important dans
le soir et ça ce sont des choses qui
sont pas négligeables
et aujourd'hui on le voit bien à travers
même le football qui se déroule en ce
moment on voit bien que les joueurs ils
sont ils sont un petit peu moins
ils sont moins motivés et aussi
l'atmosphère qui est un peu plaisante je
trouve joue aussi dans les têtes parce
que on voit que les matches
d'aujourd'hui
moins sympa ça se voit les joueurs sont
motivés et tout le monde se pose la
question donc c'est sûr que le sport il
en train de tout doucement
si on pourquoi un terrain d'entente pour
que le joueur puisse il s'entraîner et
jouer correctement ça risque d'être
compliqué aujourd'hui c'est pas sur les
jeux sociaux qu'on verra les meilleurs
et les plus belles performances
sportives
il y aura pas de record il y aura pas de
noeud ce n'est pas possible ce n'est pas
possible
restons positifs quand même avec les
avec les sportifs de haut niveau qui ont
cette chance de pouvoir s'entraîner on
prend pour thomas barrau par exemple un
exemple entre le 1er et 2e confinement
j'imagine qu'ils la campagne premier
confinement il a fait il a pu
s'entraîner uniquement avec un rameur
domestique et là il peut être sur l'eau
il ya quand même une grosse différence
je pense de réglages et de pratique de
l'aviron sur 7 sur 7 avec les postulats
la matinée suivante avec neuf en levant
la pénétration dans l'eau donc ça de
toute façon il faut pas leur enlever ça
ils ont ils ont cette possibilité
parfois très physique il avait gardé
toutes ses capacités
thomas bach ou bien par exemple il faut
garder ça m'est donc il manquera pas au
niveau il ya aussi le côté le côté
physique est important parce que au jour
d'aujourd'hui les joueurs pratiquent pas
énormément et il ya des risques de
blessure et ça c'est l'échec ou prendre
en compte les répétitions de match et si
on joue moins si on s'entraîne moins et
à des gosses risquer de se blesser donc
donc au jour d'aujourd'hui il faut aussi
trouver un rythme et qui est stable pour
tout le monde parce que si tu joues
ponant mais tant qu'on a un mois qu à
des compétitions où tu joues beaucoup et
puis après le moins d'après temps moins
de matches où on sait pas ce qui se
passe ça risque d'être compliqué aussi
donc il faut trouver une stabilité et
une forme de durabilité au fait dans les
compétitions c'est super important pour
la clé autre dérogation également qui
pourrait arriver dans les prochains
jours ça concerne le real est mineure
les premiers et 17 décembre peut-être
grégory c'est bien ça les mineurs
pourrait éventuellement pratiquer leur
sport
dimanche ses skis emmanuel macron
souhaite en tout cas alors un premier
point sera fait le 1er décembre moment
on va dire du début du déconfinement
même si ce déconfinement reste à
confirmer pour voir si la situation
sanitaire le permet c'est de permettre
aux clubs d'amateurs de reprendre les
entraînements uniquement pour les
sportifs mineurs alors il ya un
protocole renforcé qui devra être mis en
place
on parle même aussi de la mise en place
d'un masque dit respirant un tout
nouveau masque qui pourra permettre de
pratiquer avec plus de sécurité
chevalier vous êtes convaincus par ce
masque éventuellement convaincu voyons
un petit peu quelles sont les données
les données et les caractéristiques de
ce masque ce que je retiens c'est qu'il
ya eu hier à l'elysée à une grande rave
est une grande réunion du monde sportif
ou des présidents de fédérations des du
cnosf de paris 2024 etc se sont réunis
autour de roxana maracineanu de
d'emmanuel macron jean castex est haute
pour porter justement cette ses
doléances du milieu sportif et notamment
du milieu amateur et ça donne ça donne
d'ailleurs c'est plutôt il savait
écouter ils ont été sept l'espoir là cet
espoir là les mineurs puissent puisse
démarre démarre et intérêts vitaux et ce
fameux pass sport pour pouvoir relancer
un petit peu la pratique sportive dès
qu'on pourra le serbe vient du guerrier
vous savez moi je suis je suis cycliste
et j'ai du mal à comprendre que on nous
interdit d'aller faire du vélo à plus
d'un kilomètre de chez nous alors que
vannes suffire et allemand d'interdire
les regroupant et donc d'autoriser les
becs aller faire du vélo il est de faire
du vélo en sol ou tout simplement
et à partir de là il n'y aurait pas de
risque de contamination puisque on
serait seul dans la nature et donc voilà
problématique donc alors après j'ai
entendu oui mais
ça permet d'éviter les accidents et donc
de goûter les l'accueil des urgences de
cyclistes qu'il faut être renversés par
des voitures faut pas oublier qu'il ya
moins de circulation en ce moment au
quotidien et puis même si comme on a
quand même le droit de rouler avec
kilomètres de chez nous on n'a de toute
façon les mêmes les galeries dont on a
il ya dix quinze vingt kilomètres de
chez nous qu'on reste à dans ce
périmètre du kilomètre ça ne change rien
et vous savez quel est mon point de vue
par rapport à ça c'est que de toute
façon pour pouvoir combattre le mieux le
virus il faut faire du sport ont
renforcé ses défenses immunitaires
voilà donc ça c'est mon essai le même
depuis des mois et je ne le changerai
vous êtes un peu rebelle rien du jura la
république ça m'a été confirmé qu'un
signal ce que dit yann ça a été ça
n'arrête pas de mettre confirmée par le
spécialiste qui me tue à l'hôpital faut
faire du sport faut renforcer les
défenses immunitaires faut y aller
ok je vais au moins jusqu'au 1er
décembre pour faire du vélo à plus d'un
kilomètre de chez vous on sait pas
encore alors maintenant prendre le large
en cette page coup de projecteur le
départ du vendée globe 2020 a été donnée
le dimanche 8 novembre depuis les sables
d'olonne un heavy mois participent à
cette édition louis burton originaire de
rambouillet pour sa troisième
participation dans l'épreuve le skipper
du 60 18 s'en sortent plutôt bien ce
mercredi 17 novembre au moment de cette
émission
louis burton pointe à la sixième place
du classement et pourtant tout avait mal
commencé
louis burton avait réalisé un faux
départ et la franchit la ligne de deux
secondes trop vite comme le règlement
indique le jury de la course lui
infliger cinq heures de pénalité
il avait réagi à travers une vidéo on
regarde on sent très bien passé
évidemment mais on va essayer de se
rassurer en vidant
le vainqueur à l'échelle d'un vendée
globe c'est pas grand chose là
cafouillage dans le décompte entre
j'avais à l'ordinateur et puis tu
j'entendais à la vhf
c'est comme ça ça fait partie du sport
cinq heures de pénalité grégory c'est à
dire alors c'est à dire déjà il faut le
préciser si une pénalité qu'il a déjà
purgée dans la nuit du 11 au 12 novembre
c'était la semaine dernière l'illinois a
dû passer à deux reprises à la même
latitude une attitude qui se situe
environ à la hauteur de lisbonne au
portugal
et ce avec cinq heures des cards passé
deux fois la même latitude avec cinq
heures des cas c'est forcément un coup
d'arrêt on va en parler dans un instant
parce qu'il a vécu aussi des événements
particuliers 24 heures avant avec de
nombreuses avaries en raison des vents
forts au moment d'approcher le proche
atlantique avec notamment l'une de ses
cloisons structurelles qui a s'est
fissurée ça lui a permis ce temps de
pouvoir réparer son bateau et du coup il
a rattrapé un petit peu son retard il
est passé d'une 27e place vous le disiez
à une sixième place donc une course qui
se représente dans de bonnes conditions
après avoir mal commencé moi justement
regarder à la vidéo ou louis burton
s'improvise bricoleur on est sur
plusieurs chantiers en même temps sur
bureau vallée là c'est l'huile qui s'est
échappée de mon vérone qui
eux qui a coulé dans le son du bateau
qui s'est mélangé avec un peu d'eau qui
traînait et que je suis en train de
faire décanter à savoir bureau vallée
suite au programme
[Applaudissements]
grégory vous le désir le tuto bricolage
inde louis burton ce sens devrait le
faire intervenir entre notre émission si
on rentrait on présente quelques idées
d'activités à faire chez soi pourquoi
pas si mal et salage de bateaux à la
rédaction en chef
alors un petit mot sur ce faux départ je
sais que yann vous suit avec attention
ce vendée globe vous avez travaillé
cette émission pour ça ex est ce que
c'est un peu une déception de le voir
faire un faux départ
seul louis burton info déclaré alors
enfin moi je ne comprends pas enfin je
comprends pas qu'on puisse les alizés de
cinq heures une personne un athlète
parce qu'il a fait un départ anticipé de
deux secondes sur une course qui va
durer 70 jours j'ai un peu de mal avec
japonais avec le principe à la rigueur
on lui aurait dit vous faites un tour
sur vous même avec le bateau et puis et
puis allez hop c'est parti on continue
j'aurais trouvé ça beaucoup plus
cohérent faut pas qu'il faut pas faut
pas minimiser c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
5 heures la moyenne de déplacement des
bateaux c'est à peu près
20 milles nautiques c'est le pro tour de
20 milles nautiques donc cinq heures ça
fait 100 milles nautiques
aujourd'hui avec ses 100 milles
nautiques de retard en moins il serait
devant jean le cam qui a fait une super
super super 2000
voilà qui est 4e et tu fais un super
course avec avec un très très vieux
bateau qui sans foils c'est le sait le
premier d'aider nos feuilles l'heure des
noms fusent des bateaux dont foiler et
qui donc se retrouve en quatrième place
actuellement donc pendant exact est
inconnu
il a calé 4e salon pendant près d'une
semaine il a pendant près d'une semaine
il a il a bataillé avec avec alex
thomson à la tête de la course et c'est
vrai que c'était un c'est un très beau
match
surtout quand on quand on sait que la
conception du bateau il ya après une
grosse quinzaine vingtaine d'années
d'écart entre entre les deux voilà donc
voyez si on enlève les 100 miles de
moyenne que qui a perdu sur des envies
de marins pardon pas être mêlés qui l'a
perdu sur ses ceintures de pénalité
voilà aujourd'hui serait à 112 milles de
l ex thomson et donc il serait devant
jean le cam c'est quand même le seul
sport où il ya eu faute au start
quand on prend le l'athlétisme ou le ou
les courses hippiques cd photo finish
il faut justement il faut il faut
départager les arrivants là c'est quand
même bon je pense que c'est une
situation que la fédération française de
la loose n'aurait pas n'aurait pas
renier avec cette photo start où on voit
le bateau de louis burton passé deux
secondes trop tôt cette ligne de départ
n'ont pas d'arrivées de départ et
effectivement c'est foncièrement agent
alors grégory il rappelé ça lui a permis
quand même de remettre son bateau à
niveau et puis on l'a vu de ces régions
les cinq heures pendant les cinq heures
il a fait trois heures de bricolage pas
chômé il n'a pas chômé ça a été de géo
trouvetou la de là
la partie voile ce qui confirme encore
une fois que c'est que ces navigateurs
et navigatrice sont quand même les
derniers aventuriers notant d'une
polyvalence incroyable puisque ce sont
ce sont des marins aguerris ce sont des
ce sont des techniciens et là maintenant
des bricoleurs qui peuvent faire des
tutos a en pagaille donc gagner très
bien vu ça aussi exact ou d'image accès
avec le drone notamment byte le congo
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
est-ce que c'est pas un peu eu une
erreur d'expérience peut-être important
c'est son troisième vendée globe ce faux
départ
alors j'ai pas assez de recul par
rapport à ce sujet là mais ce qui est
sûr c'est que quand tu le disais tout à
l'heure c'est pas du tout cohérent
c'était par rapport à la durée de la
course au fait de l'avoir pénalisé
autant donc voilà après c'est vrai que
quand je suis bien par rapport à tout
témoin jeudi tout le monde il n'a pas
chômé l'essai de ce qui peut du mieux
possible mais j'espère que ça leur
prendra pour la prochaine donc il faut
être multitâche sur ce vendée globe on
l'a vu avec le tuto bricolage de louis
burton finalement sur ce vendée globe
il n'y a pas forcément beaucoup de casse
il ya eu seulement un seul abandon il ya
encore trente deux skippers qui sont en
course g brice et ça tout à fait le seul
abandon c'est nicolas troussel skipper
sur quorum les pins qui a abandonné
suite à un démâtage
il naviguait avec pourtant que le bateau
le plus récent de cette édition de cette
9e édition comme quoi y'a dujarrier oui
j'avais noté dents et dormait note un
seul abandon et il vaut pour rajouter
parce que je suis allé regarder un petit
peu ce qui s'était passé sur les
éditions précédentes
il faut savoir que en général il y a
seulement autour de 50% de bateaux à
l'arrivée c'est une moyenne
enfin je crois on a bossé les belles
filles
d'abord c'est le même fille
effectivement ça c'est le nombre de
marins qui ont qui sont retournés aux
sables d'olonne où ou en angleterre
donc on finit la course donc
effectivement on est on est aux
alentours de 50% le marin qui termine la
course est pour l'instant mais on est
côté un seul ce qui peut leur pardonner
pour le général et par des casses
généralement la plupart des cas ce sont
violents dans les premiers dans les
premiers moments de la course
c'est vrai que c'est rare enfin j'ai pas
les stats exact mais c'est vrai que
beaucoup de casse a eu lieu sur la
première semaine voire voir les quinze
les trois premières semaines c'était
c'est souvent le début de le début de
compétition le premier tiers de
compétition et là on n'a qu'un seul
abandon alors moi j'ai peut-être une
explication là dessus aujourd'hui si on
compare la course de alex thomson par
rapport à celle d'armel le cléac'h il y
a quatre ans ils ont un jour de retard
le bateau qui a fait ce temps les ya
quatre ans et celui de de louis burton
aujourd'hui donc ça veut dire peut-être
que les marins sont plus prudents sur
leurs leur approche de la compétition
et malgré alors les conditons peut dire
est ce que les conditions sont moins
bonnes ou pas je ne sais pas ce qui est
sûr c'est qu'ils ont vécu une dépression
la dépression et à dont on avait entendu
parler au large du portugal
et cette dépression permet quand même
d'avoir des ventes ils sont plutôt
porteur même si les conditions de mer
sont compliquées pour pouvoir surfer au
mieux et la raison pour laquelle
aujourd'hui des fouilles leur base
devant les anciens bateaux c'est que la
mer est beaucoup plus calme mais que les
vents porte beaucoup plus et donc à
partir de là les vitesses sont moins de
son son gap ayant en général on doit
gagner entre trois et quatre mille
nautique de vitesse grâce grâce aux
bonnes conditions
niveau feiler mais c'est vrai que voilà
c'est plein de petites questions que je
me pose et que je sais que j'ai encore
je pense qu'on aura les réponses au fur
et à mesure de la course et on va
pouvoir un peu plus analysé mais c'est
vrai que pour l'instant c'est assez
bizarre de voir ça que que on a un jour
de un bon jour de retard sur armel le
cléac'h
actuellement on se comprend il ya du
guerrier vous allez être sur le prochain
vendée globe
pour répondre à toutes vos questions
j'ai quatre ans pour m'entraîner mais
c'est pas du tout j'ai pas la base pour
ça je pense pas et je suis juste là en
fait juste admiratif de ce qu'ils font
et je vous cache pas que je suis mon
ordinateur en effet j'ai une fenêtre et
cette fenêtre météo
c'est au choix comment soit ça soit miss
météo non non non non pas de miss météo
désirait que j'ai cette fenêtre est très
régulièrement puisque je sais que le
classement est actualisée donc toutes
les quatre heures donc c'est à 5 heures
du matin puis ensuite à 9 heures puis
c'est toutes les trois heures jusqu'à
21h et ensuite ou 22 enfin voila je
regarde vraiment très régulièrement pour
voir les évolutions et j'aime les
chiffres et donc c'est vrai que va je
trouve ça sympa de pouvoir comparer ce
mois-ci moment avant que ces bateaux et
de comprendre comment cette course se
déroule ça me semblait donc je pense que
je suis pas le seul
il ya beaucoup de gens qui à monsieur
banier l'a recoupé ailleurs prolongé
alors en tout cas maintenant tout va
bien pour le skipper et viennois louis
burton on regarde la vidéo
tailler le sommeil et la sueur bureau
vallée
après les fronts les dépressions au bout
de six jours 9 de course on est enfin en
train de toucher un truc et au sens de
l'analyse et là c'est le bonheur il a le
sourire
grégory il a retrouvé le sourire et
aujourd'hui où il hier il a publié une
vidéo il se faisait une petite salade
d'été vue qui vont franchir bientôt
l'équateur ils vont être bientôt dans
l'hémisphère sud à l'heure où on se fait
des tartiflettes ce sont plutôt des
salades d'été avec un besoin accru de
riz du maïs voilà exactement une petite
huile d'olive aux truffes aussi là il
est à ses fins gourmets
louis burton il est dans son objectif il
s est terminé 6e et nîmes
donc pour l'instant il est encore dans
son registre parce que c'est positif a
pour l'instant son son début d' aventure
même s'il ya de la casse même si il se
faut des parce que c'est positif
finalement pierre chevallier
ah oui justement compte tenu compte tenu
du de nombreuses avaries qui là qu'il a
subi plus son faux départ
il est toujours dansé dans cet objectif
pour l'instant touchons du bois pas de
pas de dammarie grave mais donc tout ce
qu'on lui souhaite c'est de rester dans
cette logique d'objectifs est justement
de la meilleure stéphane de bizet c'est
positif je suis tellement je suis
tellement ravie tu me donne la parole
juteux juste ils sont passionnés par
proto noix ou quoi ou pas encore diaries
est bien là moi je me suis renseigné
quand même la même chanson drame
je pense qu'une il avait émerveillé par
rapport au projet de l'info il risque
d'être un petit peu moins difficile à
passer que
que que les années précédentes il risque
d'y avoir un pot-au-noir un peu moins un
peu moins difficiles les conditions
risquent d'être un peu meilleures pour
pouvoir le passer
et en effet c'est vrai que c'est une
phase de la course ou régulièrement on
voit des bateaux et des navigateurs qui
sont qu'ils sont désespérés parce que
magna pains paix devant et ça ne fait
pas du tout avancer le bateau vient
suggériez ou est-ce que vous situer le
pot-au-noir juste pour l'été spectateurs
ou est-ce que ça si tu en as prix bas
notamment de l'équateur quoi voilà c'est
large du brésil
merci pour toutes ces précisions a gagné
7 au large de la fuite
je suis juste rajouter un truc parce que
normalement il c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas
eu l'info et c'est quelque chose que je
voulais je voulais voir avant l'avant là
avant lui avant l'émission est pour
l'instant d'apple une info il devrait il
y avoir un lancement de trophée jules
verne le trophée jules verne c'est le
même type de course
ils vont partir un peu petit peu plus
hot du nord de la bretagne au large de
ouessant et ils vont faire exactement le
même parcours
ce qui veut dire que alors c'est pas le
même bateau c'est un bateau beaucoup
plus grand c'est un trimaran mais
simplement le trophée jules verne c'est
une course qui il donc il faut un même
tour du monde et ils vont mettre une
quarantaine de jours pour le réaliser il
faut savoir que le vent des blogs ces
soixante dix jours donc ça veut dire que
là aujourd'hui on est sur un dixième
dixième jour de course du vendée globe
est donc ce bateau qui devrait partir
dans l'est dans les jours prochains
devraient doubler le vendée globe
autour du 30e 40e jour de course 30e
jour de course pardon il c'est vrai que
ça peut être ça peut être sympa de voir
ce bateau doublé doublé les imoca voilà
merci andy jarrier en tout cas vous avez
bien travaillé je vous en félicite
merci beaucoup repas c'est maintenant
notre page des bas dans cette page débat
c'est votre rubrique grégory nous
l'avons baptisé à l'envolée de grégory
une fois n'est pas coutume vous avez
choisi de démarrer votre envolés par une
image regardez ce cliché a été pris le
11 novembre dernier lors d'un match
d'eurocoupe de basket entre nanterre et
gran canaria l'accent espagnol est allé
chez une photo assez impressionnante
c'est celle à deux victoires wemba nyama
saison seulement et 2 mètres 19 déjà
pour le jeune pivot a lors de la
victoire des français face aux espagnols
il n'a joué que huit minutes 0 point 0
rebonds et un seul contre
voici ces statistiques mais il a tout de
même fait le buzz
victor wanyama avec cette image montrant
son envergure exceptionnelle
yes pn parle d'un potentiel
extraterrestre fox sports de meilleurs
prospects du monde de sa classe d'âge
oui car le natif du chesnay qui a débuté
d'ailleurs à l'entente le
chesnay-versailles attire déjà l'oeil
outre-atlantique lui qui a un profil
similaire à rudy gobert et qui est
considéré comme le plus grand espoir du
basket français
cette année il effectue sa première
vraie saison chez les pros alternant
entre des matchs avec l'équipe à de
nanterre et le centre fédéral en
national un début en douceur donc son
coach pascal donnadieu prévoit d'en
faire un joueur majeur du collectif dès
l'an prochain et on attend déjà avec
impatience une année l'année 2023 il
aura 19 ans et pourra être drafté en nba
et les observateurs prédisent déjà à
victor wanyama une première place pour
cette draft mais trois ans c'est long
l'illinois doit continuer sa progression
éviter des blessures il est très grand
c'est que les blessures peuvent arriver
quand
physique se développe assez vite et il
faut aussi qu'il garde la tête sur les
épaules alors ça on n'a pas de doute
avec ça il a plutôt un bon entourage
autour de lui tout comme si on élargit à
d'autres pépites il y en a de nombreuses
dans les yvelines dans le sport
yvelinois qui sont comme un département
vous les suivez régulièrement mitchell
on a parlé dans cette émission de
d'antoine bibeau dos il a 15 ans c'est
un prodige du tennis qui s'entraîne au
comité de tennis des yvelines de
feucherolles ils étaient en lice lors du
dernier roland garros juniors pour une
première participation éliminé au
deuxième tour mais par des joueurs qui
par un joueur en l'occurrence le
brésilien gustavo wade a quitté de trois
ans son aîné il avait 18 ans au moment
où il a affronté il est aussi léobard et
les aubrystes un jeune rugbyman
originaire de versailles qui a rejoint
lé randstad française voit pierre qui
exulte à côté de moi il ay il a rejoint
le stade français l'été dernier libinois
a le potentiel pour devenir le futur
demi d'ouverture du quinze de france il
est passé par massy il évolue
actuellement avec l'équipe de france des
moins de 20 ans et comment parler des
pépites yves binois sans évoquer et
jimmy elias l as du volant à seulement
11 ans le guillant courtois fait partie
de la team tony kart c'est le plus jeune
champion du monde
je suis jeune plus jeune champion je
vais y arriver de l'histoire de
l'automobile français rassure un mini
car tu sais c'était à 7 ans et 10 mois
jimmy alias donc il ya beaucoup
d'attentes autour de lui il fait partie
des pilotes les plus suivies en europe
il était engagé cette année dans le
championnat mini 60 qui est gérée par la
fia c'est la fédération internationale
de l'automobile
bref que des promesses pour ses futurs
grands champions sur le papier mais
encore voilà c'est on nous dit c'est sur
le papier ce n'est qu'un échantillon
c'est de ces pépites au niveau yvelinois
nous relayons ici michael leurs
performances vous l'avais dit en tant
que média local
nous devons être un miroir de
l'actualité locale de qui ce qu'il se
passe sur le territoire
mais laissons ces pépites un laissons
les à travailler tranquillement sans
être sous le feu des projecteurs des
starification trop précoces peuvent
conduire à deux cuisants échecs les
exemples sont nombreux et notamment dans
le sport qui m'anime le plus c'est le
football de combien de joueurs at on dit
qu'ils étaient les futurs zidane
au final ces espoirs se sont brûlé les
ailes trop
vitraux tiraillé par la pression
médiatique peut être aussi mal entouré
ils n'ont pas fait forcément les bons
choix au bon moment dans leur carrière
et on ne peut être que frustré de voir
le parcours de certains joueurs citons
l'exemple d'hatem ben arfa qui est passé
par versailles formés dans les yvelines
à clairefontaine
pétri de talent et dont la carrière n'a
pas été à la hauteur des attentes et je
n'ai qu'un message à passer ici à
l'éventuelle c'est laisser les jeunes
travaillent en empêche est ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec grégory oui ou non
oui tout le monde est d'accord et
grégory vous d'accord oui vous êtes
d'accord
mike au congo vous êtes a eu bien sûr il
faut laisser ces jeunes y travailler en
paix oui bien sûr bien sûr pour les
laisser faut les laisser travailler en
paix et il ya un facteur qui est
important c'est d'abord le l'entourage
la famille et et en plus moi je pars
toujours du principe où il ya des étapes
qu'il faut pas griller au jour
d'aujourd'hui pour eux ce qui est
important c'est de se développer c'est
se perfectionner c'est apprendre leur
métier et essayer de progresser ensuite
petit à petit graver les échelons c'est
sûr qu'il faut pas leur mettre trop de
règles dans leur tête parce que au jour
d'aujourd'hui avec des réseaux sociaux
avec tout ce qui se passe autour du
sport et autour de l'argent et j'ai
l'impression que les jeunes
d'aujourd'hui ils ont tendance à être
moins patients ils ont envie d'arriver
très très vite
donc d'où l'entourage familial qui est
qui est primordial pour puis après s'il
travaille sérieusement bien sûr qu'ils
sont forcément recrutés par les mairies
victor wanyama c'est un jour vous
connaissez j'imagine mal au congo alors
personnellement je ne connais pas je
sais que rudy gobert qui était sur paris
l'a récemment s'y entraînaient un peu
avec lui nous on a touché des mots aussi
par rapport à ça mais c'est vrai qu'au
jour d'aujourd'hui et quand on voit sa
taille
c'est le genre de joueur est vachement
recherché dans le basket tout court mais
la nba c'est sûr que ce genre de
potentiel à les intéresse forcément
parce que la nba c'est un basket qui
jouant au jour d'aujourd'hui il faut
savoir qu'on parle
le basket ball les joueurs sont beaucoup
plus grands et forcément il va il va
attirer les et de par son envergure
aussi maintenant ce qui est ce qui est
sûr pour lui c'est que c'est que voilà
il doit continuer à travailler mais
c'est sûr que la porte n 10 et les lieux
ouverts d'institutions c'est pas comme
des joueurs qui font un mètre 81 20 90
ou à accéder à la nba beaucoup plus
difficile mais ce genre de joueurs là
ils ont ils ont rarement le potentiel
pour pouvoir y arriver rapidement
il est sûr d'y être un levier dans trois
ans
honnêtement s'il n'est pas blessé et
s'il continue à progresser
c'est sûr qu'il va y être après on
connaît des joueurs des basketteurs
comme johan petro que je pourrais très
bien jérôme moïso à l'époque qui font
aussi à peu près 2 m 16 de mes 18 ans
qui ont été en nba et qui n'ont pas pu
faire carrière aussi parce qu'après il
n'était pas sérieux après faut atterrir
sur la bonne équipe donc il ya tous ces
facteurs là le but c'est jeudi toujours
peu importe ce qu'on fait c'est c'est de
durer
c'est de durer et de fair carrire donc
le but c'est pas simplement qu'ils
arrivent en nba que deux ancres et se
retrouve en europe parce qu'on a eu
énormément d'exemples comme ça récemment
on a le on à kevin séraphin qui a été
drafté aussi qui appartient à une bille
et qui a pas pu faire carrière qui
revenu en europe après a eu des
problèmes de blessures et au jour
d'aujourd'hui là il a dû prendre prendre
sa retraite à seulement 28 ans donc
donc voilà un cachet un gâchis dont il
faut bien préparer ces gamins là il faut
que les entraîneurs puissent bien
travailler avec eux et il faut que les
parents puissent jouent aussi leur rôle
et que les agents les laisse tranquilles
aussi c'est super important
grégory canal et de précision juste pour
dire qu'il n'a pas forcément fils du
grand dire un victor wang banyan depuis
il a 16 ans il fait deux mètres 19 pas
encore grandir sa croissance n'est pas
terminée et deuxième chose je parlais de
l'année 2023 pour une potentielle draft
nba puisque le règlement aujourd'hui dit
que les clubs ne peuvent pas vous drafté
à 19 ans enfin c'est le l'âge minimum
ses 19 ans ils sont intenses
effectivement et ce en train de discuter
en nba d'abaisser cet âge à 18 ans dont
on pourrait avoir un drap l'une draft
pour pour victor d'aidé l'année 2022
en deux ans il ya dujarrier vous donne
la parole ensuite pierre oui dans le cas
de victor il et je connais bien son père
je sais que déjà l'an passé il aurait pu
y aller je crois du côté de barcelone
mais il est il est très très très bien
heures entouré par sa famille qui ont
décidé de de les laisser de le laisser
évoluer step by step de façon à ce qu'il
puisse arriver enfin de le laisser
tranquille gré dans son cocon il est pas
comment tenir parce qu'elle est les
requins américain qui arrive ce qui
commence à l'entourer mais il est très
bien entouré par son père il faut dire
aussi pour la draft de 2022
mais on a quand même deux qui sont
devant lui donc c'est pas encore gagné
il a il faut qu'ils travaillent et la
force majeure de victor c'est qu'il est
malgré sa taille il est aussi adroit à
trois points que intérieur raquette et
il avait un premier match a pas
longtemps avec la nationale une de
nanterre et il a carrément écoeuré les
attaquants adverses
il aura carrément marcher dessus donc il
progresse il travaille bien on a
confiance pour pour l'avenir mais n'est
pas encore gagnée pour la draft
c'était fin de buzet vous dites que il
est bien protégé qu'il est dans un cocon
on peut le dire mais ça n'empêche pas
quand même les médias de s'y intéresser
et la pression sera forcément de plus en
plus élevés pour un jeune gamin ci lui a
consacré un centre il ya deux jours
l'équipe heures mais depuis l'an depuis
l'an dernier déjà les américains
commençant l'entouré on va dire ça
commence à arriver mais il est très très
très bien entouré et pense que ça va le
nigeria
oui moi je voulais juste parce que quand
je vois les photos moi je connaissais je
connais pas du tout le garçon quand je
vois les photos il ya une photo où on
voit ya trois garçons de la même équipe
vie et et je vois une grosse grosse
différence de musculature en effet il
est très très grand mais il est très
longiligne et donc je enfin moi je
m'entoure est surtout de deux médecins
deux kinés pour pouvoir et de
nutritionnistes pour ne pas faire
d'erreur parce que en nba il ya une
chose qui est sûre c'est que et puis de
toute façon en basket en basket en
général c'est quand même un sport qui
est devenu très très très physique et en
effet si demain il a une blessure il se
fait il se fait les croisés ou un truc
comme ça il peut dire adieu à sa
carrière
on se remet pas d'une blessure tel ou
tel que les croisés aussi facilement
donc voila moi vraiment le si j'avais un
enfant avec ces qualités là les je ferai
attention à la nutrition je ferai
attention à beaucoup d'éléments qui
serait simplement basé sur la santé oui
bien sûr que le travail qui doit être
fait par les clubs pour lui apprendre à
shooter pour lui faire gagner
d'expérience il est important mais s'il
se blesse il se met en en croix eh bien
on pourra rien en tirer derrière donc
faisons la base avant avant de avant
d'aller trop vite
voilà dans la liste de
de grégory et surtout sur son slogan de
laisser les jeunes travailler ce qui
étonnant de noter c'est que la plupart
des cas des cas où vous voulez où les
jeunes se sont brûlé les ailes c'était
plutôt du football et tous les autres
sports ont peut être un petit peu plus
optimistes parce que peut-être les
enjeux sont moins forts les enjeux
financiers sont moins forts peut-être
aussi que les entourages sont plus
matures les familles sont beaucoup plus
présentes
donc là tout le monde l'a rappelé
notamment pour pour ce jeune basketteur
pour le connaître je sais aussi que les
oléo bareille côté stade français équipe
de france de rugby est très bien entouré
très bien conseillé justement et que il
comprend le temps de façonner ses
diamants bruts
donc je serais plus optimiste sur la
partie basket sur le rugby sur le sur le
tennis par exemple aussi avec antoine
rigaudeau on met mettant un petit peu le
football à part parce que là c'est tout
tout de suite très rapide je me souviens
aussi de ce qui avait été faudrait
peut-être plus en amont notamment à
l'époque du havre et de d'anthony le
tallec et de soir au cinéma pongolle
avec gérard houllier de liverpool qui
vient les drailles qui vient pas les
draft et les délais superviser de
liverpool et qui vient justement mettre
entre guillemets la main sur leur sur
leur avenir
mais c'est prendre le temps justement
kim nature qu'ils soient bien formés
physiquement
il ya le rappeler c'est hyper important
de de favoriser la croissance de pouvoir
aussi s'adjoindre les services de kiné
de kiel et de préparateurs physiques
pour justement bien mature heures au
niveau physique mais on a suffisamment
d'expérience maintenant d'expérience
raté leur rendez-vous raté pour pouvoir
justement bien bien choyé ses futurs ces
figurants il arrive souvent en football
le fait que des espoirs se brûle les
ailes mais il ya l'exemple du tennis les
nouveaux membres est ce qu'on n'en parle
pas plus finalement dans le football que
dans les eaux oui un grand pôle tennis
l'exemple de nouveaux mousquetaires on a
comparé gilles simon monfils gasquet
tsonga ou les nouveaux mousquetaires on
les a comparés aux anciens mousquetaires
notamment la cause borotra et cetera
brugnon est également donc ça existe
aussi dans d'autres sports le fait qu'on
mette trop vite sur le devant de la
scène des jeunes espoirs mais on l'aimé
parce qu'ils ont des qualités c'est pas
marketing aussi de le faire finalement
ce qui peut être assurée aussi ce à quoi
on a beau on a beaucoup d'éclat des
bonnes écoles et les bonnes écoles de
formation dans tous les sports déjà rien
et des tonga des monfils des ils ont
fait des belles carrières non plus et
puis qui sont même pas terminé faut pas
déconner oui bien sûr qu'ils viennent
pas de tournois du grand chelem mais ils
gagnent des compétitions à pépé à très
haut niveau
on n'est pas oublier que afin d'aider
comme on s'appelle des tennismans qui
gagne des tournois du grand chelem sur
les 40 dernières années
il y en a pas beaucoup quand on voit que
la dalle il a pris très à roland garros
où je ne sais plus je j'arrive plus à
compter mais voilà il ya un moment où
des mecs qui sont karl vernay tour des
grands chefs ça se compte sur les doigts
de deux de demain quoi donc oui on a pas
français mais ils viennent et ils sont
sortis design à rentrer dans les dix
meilleurs mondiaux à une période de leur
de leur intérieur c'est à rire quand
même on va terminer on va terminer cette
émission peut être par un message pour
dire juste qu'elle
oui ces femmes pour moi le plus bel
exemple de footballeur qui a été starisé
trop tôt pour moi c'est christian
gourcuff
un gourcuff yoann gourcuff c'est pour
moi c'est plus belle escroquerie qui
s'est complètement perdus ici les
cessions n'ont rien ça c'est le football
le football c'est pas mes deux mondes
moi je pourrais prendre l'exemple de
danser crise
l'exemple d'une pépite que l'on a et qui
qui va continuer de fleurir avec
mathilde gros voilà qui vient de nulle
part
et aujourd'hui c'est l'association sur
le temps où je me situe le sur piste et
on l'a eu mais on la façade
tranquillement on prend un temps et oui
peut-être qu'elle sera championne des
championnes olympiques en 2024
mais c'est pas grave parce que les
enjeux ne sont pas les mêmes le football
oui faut au foyer vie mais non c'est pas
comme ça qu'un sportif ça se construit
un sportif un sportif ça se construit
sur la durée
amy et michael a dit bien sûr que c'est
important de durée bien sûr individuelle
et sports collectifs sports individuels
reprendre tes l'exemple du tennis on
attend depuis 83 qu'un français gagne à
nouveau à roland garros après yannick
noah et dans les sports collectifs
phares on est on est deux fois champion
du monde de football on espère l'être en
2023 au but donc c'est passé pas les
mêmes conditions de maturation dernier
mot avec vous un michael mokongo qu'est
ce qu'on peut lui souhaiter à victor
wanyama ça sera
a le dernier mot sur cette émission on
va lui fêté d'abord la santé c'est la
chose la plus importante est de
continuer à travailler fondation c'est
tout ce qu'on ait évoqué aujourd'hui
et puis et puis lescure hélène vié et
surtout de durée et d'avoir la même
carrière que tony parker voit là le
bémol
merci à la fin de cette émission va
terminer comme par une incitation
aujourd'hui je vous propose une citation
du français pierre de coubertin
rénovateur des jeux olympiques de l'ère
moderne
le sport va chercher la peur pour la
dominer la fatigue pour en triompher la
difficulté pour la vaincre joue laisse
méditer sur cette phrase à bientôt sur
tv 78
[Musique]